for those just tuning in from both chats
we're doing uh
an opening lesson collaboration this is
anna crownling right above me on my
stream
hello um oh on your stream too okay so
pointing up makes sense
i guess what we could start with is some
um
just some basic traps like kind of show
the initial move order
um i'm gonna be i'm gonna be careful i
don't wanna like overwhelm you because
when you start learning spanish
there's so many different branches at
every kind of juncture in the opening
um of course after bishop e5 like this
is uh
initial like initial starting position
of spanish
and we'll look at traps from the white
side and for the black side
yeah um i actually have a few in mind to
start off with
where black is trapping white
and the most common move here is asics
uh which i looked up i think about
70 to 80 of games feature a6 if you look
at like the whole
like mega database um of course there's
already other options for black there's
uh there's g6
there's 97 there's g6 there is a
schliemann
f5 is actually an interesting and
playable
playable move um there's berlin of
course
which is super common at like the the
higher levels
so as a spanish player you
um you kind of have to be ready for all
the different
responses black and play
but with that said like even if you're
brand new to the opening and your
opponent surprises you
on move what is this
move three uh a lot of the same
principles apply like usually you want
to castle put the rook on e1
usually go for c3 d4 so there's general
kind of themes you can play against most
of what black will play
but we'll start with a6 and
the first line i'll share with you is
the line i
i would share like any beginner player
who's like brand new to the spanish
um and it's very possible you've seen
this one before
um because a lot of newer players will
think that white's just winning a pawn
here
where you can take on c6 and take on e5
um which is not good for white
have you seen this one before yeah i
recognize this
so this is black to move and figure out
how to essentially punish
white's last move um
is it is it queen d4
yeah queen d4 is uh is remarkably strong
here
and this is the case it's justified to
bring your queen out early you're gonna
win back the pawn
and not only that white will have to
retreat the knight you win back the pawn
and you take away
white's castling rights that's why
you'll either have to play king f1 or
queen e2 and
like black is already for choice with
the bishop pair and a relatively open
position
so a lot of newer players will walk into
that
um now i should mention
like after bishop c6 this is exchange
variation which
uh it's playable it's not super common
um i'll share one more just simple trap
for black
um let's say white doesn't take on e5
but castles
king side most common move um the main
line
and also maybe the trickiest line is to
play bishop g4
pinning the knight there's cases where
white wants to play d4 so bishop g4
prevents d4
and then most common move is h3 here
and now in this position black has like
a really tricky move
which i'm curious if you're if if you
would be able to consider
so black to move play the trickiest move
okay um
maybe h5 yep and i
i see people in your chat were saying h5
more so than people in my chat
so uh very nice h5 is uh is known as the
fishing pole trap
yeah so if you're gonna put it in other
openings
yeah it's a very typical idea across
multiple openings and yeah
um i guess same thing with cuisines like
fish is just
a common type of food across different
types of cuisine
um but you like food
i i like certain types of fish i stay
away from the more exotic
like i don't really like octopus
or the i don't know people
sometimes people eat well or i stick
with the classic like
tuna and salmon so okay or shrimp
so no shark no whale nothing like that
for you
no no dolphin no no oh do people eat
dolphins
i don't know i was just naming fish type
okay eats
dolphins mammals anyway
so they call this a fishing pole because
the bishop
is bait and black is the one trying to
go fishing
so if white takes a bait it's already
very very troublesome for white and i
was looking this
up in the online database earlier
and there's been hundreds of people that
have fallen into this variation
where they lose instantly like they'll
take the pawn in e5
and black is already mating by force i
believe
with queen h4 and this is the whole
point of the trap is to open the h file
and white has no way to stop mates um i
think there's been almost a thousand
games i've gone like f3
and uh then after g3 black can
black and pre-move queen h1 mate
wow so yeah
goes to show that uh sometimes you
should not
accept free food by taking the bishop
nope nope we i typically advocate for
always trying to like take all pawns and
you know then just figuring out how to
save your position but
sometimes that doesn't work and this is
one of those times right
and this is actually a main line like um
if you look this position up
in the database like there's been a lot
of grand master games here
where black just leaves a bishop on g4
main line is d3 white will normally
develop with like bishop e3
knight d2 later go for d4 um
and there are lines i don't want to go
into because uh we should probably focus
on more main lines but
uh it's a playable line that if you play
against the spanish you should um
you should be prepared for exchange
variation
um if you play the spanish as white and
you play exchange variation you should
be ready for this line
so anyway those were the two kind of
basic traps in exchange spanish the
fishing pole trap
and that immediate like queen d4 trap
um i'll share one more
trap for black which is a more maybe uh
closer to main line and most common move
here for white is to just retreat the
bishop
and leave the tension and the next trap
i'll show you
i would actually recommend flipping the
board look from blackside
um because this next one i learned when
i was about eight years old
my first chess coach taught this one to
me i use it
with like a lot of success over the
years um
and it starts with a move d6
which at first looks like uh it looks
like a normal move
but it also doesn't look like the most
accurate move because we're
locking into a pin and we're inviting
the move d4 from white
which looks really strong to try and
exploit the pin maybe threatening d5
um but when white plays d4 it's already
beginning to walk into the trap
um have you heard of the the name uh the
noah's ark trap
i have not no okay because that's the
one i'm about to show you
it gets its name because it's like i
think it's so old
um and it's just i'm starting to love
this with black i'm not gonna lie i'm
gonna start playing e5 as well with
black
yeah i guess i'm giving you motivation
to play against the spanish all these uh
these tricky traps
so the drawback of d4 is black can
immediately
seize initiative rather than capturing
we start with b5 just hitting the bishop
force bishop b3
and then we take on d4 i recommend
taking with knight
and the most natural continuation for
white is just to take back twice
so it takes takes takes at this point
white has already fallen into the trap
and now it's back to move and win
material
and this will be a tactic for you and
for chat
c5 c4
yeah c5 okay it's not that simple though
you play c5 and white will play queen d5
um i mean
bishop i guess bishop e6 yeah so bishop
e6
is one of the only moves to not get
mated or lose a rook
uh now let's say the queen goes into c6
a line keeps going
uh bishop d7 i'll move back
i'll move back and offer a draw but you
decline the draw of course
yeah yeah c4 so um
yeah it's a cool line because black is
essentially keeps initiative the whole
way
at first it looks like black's in
trouble after queen d5 but we
uh we fend off the threats and when the
bishop's on d7 the rook's defended this
is the only threat and
c4 cuts off the battery so
when i was younger i've had this uh a
good handful of times like playing in
scholastic events and open tournaments
and um nice way to win material early
then there's a bonus trap
from this position because usually light
will take twice
on on a c4
we casually develop and then if light
castles
we throw another punch with bishop e5
and we win more material
so um anyway that's the gist of the
noah's ark trap
another reason why white has to be
careful kind of
entering black's preparation
now i could show you a counter to this
first of all if you're white
and black plays g6 there's a lot of
moves you can play you don't have to
play d4 immediately
um i could potentially recommend c3 that
way you give your bishop a retreating
square and
your bishop's not getting trapped but if
you go into this line
d4 so what we just saw
trade on d4 um queen takes d4 is a
blunder
but white can play a gamut here c3
and if i knew my opponent is gonna try
and trap me with the nose arc trap
i would very likely go into this line
and play c3
and basically treat it as a gambit where
um then black is kind of the one who
might be caught off guard
and if black accepts the gambit um
here there's a couple options for whites
white can take back and there's some
interesting compensation you have more
development
uh there's still some idea with queen d5
if i was playing let's say a strong
grand master
or let's say i'm playing like magnus
carlson in this position
and he takes on c3 there's a way for
white to force a draw which i'd probably
be happy to
to do against a strong gm
um and it's using the same or similar
idea from what we just saw
in the other variation so how can white
just force a draw right away
i mean i'm thinking queen d5 queen c6
but
i guess that maybe the king can go to e7
worst case but
i guess yeah i guess forcing the word
forcing is maybe
a strong word um if black chooses to go
to e7
then then white will have a really
strong advantage and black is taking a
huge risk
like he wouldn't do that he wouldn't go
to e7
i don't think he would do this in like a
slow game maybe he would do this in like
an online game if he uh
he wants to still play it for a win yeah
uh i just checked with the engine
engine's getting almost plus
three for white after it just takes on
c3 yeah
it looks so so so weak for black i mean
all the light squares e5
knight d5 the king is ridiculous ah
yeah this um delayed bomb cloud is not
not such a great opening here
so anyway this these are um sometimes
this will happen
in different opening lines where um
one side can like go for a fourth straw
line where if you're a much stronger
player then you have to avoid like if
you're playing this as black
uh you may not want to
to enter this line because of c3
then um you either have to like go into
the draw line or kind of just accept a
worse position
yeah okay that's really cool i like to
see through
okay finally i'm starting to like this
with white too c3 was a nice move
yeah and like if if you know who you're
gonna
like if you know your opponent
beforehand and you see that they're
gonna play
uh this trap against the spanish then uh
then maybe you can surprise them go into
it and then uh
and then get them with something like
this
um so anyway those are kind of the
initial appetizers
um just like easy kind of feel good
opening traps
i could maybe give you one more one more
track because
i didn't have this one prepared
initially but a memory just came to mind
when i was about 1900
this was back in 2007 i was learning how
to play the spanish and i played it for
the first time
um i played the spanish when i was like
around eight years old but then i came
back to it when i was around 13 or 14
years old
um i played it in a serious tournament
and my opponent hit me with f5 is of
schliemann
the schliemann gambit
and i'm sharing this with you because
it's a trap that i wish i had studied
before i actually played
the spanish in a serious game so this is
a brand new move for me i
had no idea like how white should react
to this
i will say there's a lot of acceptable
moves here white can take on c6 like
complete d3 knight c3
during the game i thought that i would
try and
complicate things as much as possible
and try and like get my opponent out of
their
their preparation and then in doing so i
just walked into like the most basic
trap of this opening
um and the move i played is d4
which actually looks kind of intuitive
very thematic when
black especially when black pushes f
pawn early on you want to just make the
center open up and exploit the
opponent's king unfortunately
my opponent was prepared for this took
on e4
i only have really one logical move to
take on e5
and then black still plays forcingly
takes on
e5 pawn takes e5
at first glance this position looks
completely fine for white
um because the king is more exposed
white's ready to castle
um but this is already black to move and
win material by force
there's a nice little kind of tactical
idea from this position despite black
has nothing
really developed
oh um
i'm looking at like
that doesn't win material the bishop can
just go back i was looking at some like
c6 and then like queen a5
but there's some way
because the bishop just goes back to e2
oh you want to play queen a5 to win the
bishop
yeah yeah exactly like c6 bishop a4
queen a5
you have exactly the right idea okay
but you you actually you have the right
execution but the wrong idea
okay usually it's it's flipped like
you'll have the the right
idea but wrong execution you're
executing perfectly you just have to see
what else is hanging for white
what's the other target in the position
i mean we have the pawn on e5
yeah yeah so when you play c6 you're not
interest
you know of course you're attacking the
bishop but you're more interested in
winning the pawn
oh i was going for big things here
yeah you wanted the dessert before you
eat the appetizer yeah that's true
i was too greedy okay yeah that makes
sense
but yeah after c6 white is is uh
white is losing material wherever the
bishop moves
uh queen a5 now white will have some
compensation
but uh there's been a lot of games here
and black will score much better because
d5 is coming
and black develops really quickly
so there is black yeah yeah so i guess
this is one reason to play
f5 is uh it's a good handful of players
will play d4 and just walk into this
trap
now if you're playing the white side you
can still get away with playing d4
enter this position and if you want to
be really aggressive as white you can
willingly enter this position and play a
really cool sacrifice
you just leave your bishop here and play
knight c3
allow them to take and then take on e4
and this position is really really sharp
and double-edged and
probably a bit too spicy for me but uh
if white's prepared here like black is
under serious pressure
so um there's always more layers of
the opening preparation to to peel back
i love it i i love sacrificing i'm
i think it's because throughout my whole
life i've been so afraid of sacrificing
sacrificing like over-the-board
tournaments because there's been like so
much at stake but now when i play online
i just sacrifice so much because i have
like
all those years of like you know caving
in and not doing it i can just like
throw that
when i'm playing online and this is the
type of stuff that i love this is great
it's fun to do yeah especially in like
blitz and bullet where you put your
opponent under pressure right away and
they're the ones having to defend um
this is actually my style when i
when i play like online speed chess but
internment chess i usually like the more
solid and positional
uh battles but uh it's nice to mix
things up
the best thing is when like you you know
you're opening so well that you know
that you can throw out traps and your
opponent falls for them
it feels really really good definitely
yeah it's
uh it's one of the things that brings me
like the most joy in chess is like
trapping people early and then
then winning a game without even having
to think because i relying on
things that i've studied in the past so
i'll share
the next thing i want to share is
actually a full game but it's still kind
of based on the trap
and it's against it's also okay so it's
a game where white will win very quickly
and
it's against kind of an offbeat line for
black
what i'm going to show you is a game i
played a few months ago
online and i actually managed to figure
out the trap without
without studying it before um i'll
explain
afterwards like how i managed to do it
but
um the line my opponent played was
knight
ge7 which is already an offbeat move
like the main move black will usually
play as knight f6
and then um again there's a lot of
branches
but uh for now we'll focus on knight e7
just maybe more trendy these days a lot
of players are playing g6 and bishop g7
and kind of getting the the fiend on the
king side
um against this i i decided to mix
things up
like most spanish players will castle
play c3
eventually go for d4 i wanted to
develop as quickly as possible so i
started with knight c3
opponent play g6 and then i play d4 so
i'm wasting no time
not even spending time to castle i want
to strike in the center
right away before black can get the king
safe
black took here
now my next move is probably the first
like real surprise move
of the game so it looks most logical to
take
i went for knight d5 so already gamuting
upon like not recapturing
but knight d5 has like a very uh nice
threat to it
uh if black plays b5 white to move this
is more a question for chat
let's see which shaq can find it first
chat
figure it out i think your chat found it
first
good job to yasser for president that's
an amazing username
knight of six checkmates oh my child is
finding it now too
yeah very nice kind of early smother
mates yeah
yeah have you ever been able to
checkmate somebody like that over the
world
over the board i can't recall
online many times yeah over the board
people will usually especially in the
tournament game people will be
decent enough not to to fall for
something like this
what about you i beat like uh i think it
was like 1900
yeah it was like 1900 like almost 2 000
with not like a knight of six
trackmate but with a checkmate where my
queen was on e2
the e file was open and i had a 96
checkmate
oh you like moved six or seven or was it
from the caro khan
there's a famous like trap in cairo khan
no it was from the banco or my opponent
playing the vanco
oh the banco okay i i think i know what
uh a trap you're you're talking about
it's another like common idea which can
occur across like many different types
of openings
for sure yeah um and some people just
have a blind spot
like usually when especially when it's
early on you just assume the squares in
your territory are defended but uh
f6 can be a very costly blind spot for
black
for sure for sure yeah anyway in this
game my opponent
played more most normal move bishop g7
covering f6 defending the pawn i went
for bishop g5
uh pinning the knight and now i'm
threatening to take this knight
and then win material by taking on e7
so my opponent played a very natural
move
upon b5 uh hitting my bishop
i think most players here as white
especially if this were like blitz or
bullet
would immediately play bishop b3
um but this is a very important lesson
is that whenever your opponent plays a
move like b5
and it looks like you have one obvious
response
you don't want to play it right away you
want to always be searching for
potential counter-attacks and in this
position i don't move my bishop
turns out there's a stronger move and
i'll give this to you i'll give this
also to chat is white to move and find
the
strongest way of counter-attacking
the first thing that comes to mind is
bishop f6 but
uh i'm not sure if that is because
if they take the bishop on a4 then you
can take on g7 and you have this knight
of six threat
of checkmate at the same time as you're
threatening the rook so
uh oh so you're saying i'll just move
make the move so bishop a6 if we trade
we're threatening this
and this so this could be a pretty
brutal mate
yeah so that's the first thing that
comes to mind but i'm not sure if
there's anything else
i will say bishop f6 is definitely a
candidate move along with knight f6 of
course
um i want you to keep searching for
candidate moves
i'm looking in both chats it looks like
there's one person in each chat
who's considered like the strongest move
um i will say there's a lot of people
saying knight f6
which uh like looks really strong
because
we're invading dark square if takes
takes we uh get a super dominant bishop
the issue with knight f6 is king f8 and
it's still a little bit unclear like our
bishop's still attacked
h6 and g5 might be coming um
another option a lot of people are
saying is like takes on e7
um but only ends up trading like
whatever it takes on e7 black will take
back
and our bishop will still be hanging oh
maybe um
maybe knight takes d4 so knight takes d4
is a move that's that's played it's the
strongest move
but in order to play this move you kind
of have to see
what happens next yeah so knight takes
d4 and the idea was that if bishop takes
d4 i wanted to take on e7
um that was the idea
with the
i mean like first impression was just to
take with the bishop
um with the bishop on e7 then take on
d4 with the queen and threaten the rook
gotcha
you're along the right lines first of
all there's there's a lot of choices
black has here
if black takes a bishop then we can take
on c6 and win e7
um and of course if black takes with a
knight on d4 then we trap the queen
so bishop d4 is probably like the most
um most likely move which is what my
opponent played
and then you were saying to take on e7
and take on
like takes takes takes which looks
really really nice for lights
there's a checkmate isn't there but
there's a stronger move in this position
queen takes d4 takes d4 is uh
is not only more aesthetic but it's the
best move too
yeah and it's a beautiful uh oh no my
queen
sacrifice because when
or if black takes it then we get a
really uh really
beautiful mates with the knight and the
bishop
not quite smothered mate i'm sure
there's a name for this mating pattern
but uh
it's a nice one so this is what happened
in in my game i click on d4 uh
opponent of course realize like if
you're sometimes if you can take a free
queen you have to
watch out for the trap so my point
realized that uh
there's a mating threat and black
castled in this position
um which almost saves black however now
it's light to move and find the force
mate
it already looks really bad for black
because the dark squares are
really really weak we have the queen the
knight the bishop
all staring down
knight f6 track 98 check and then
checkmate on g7
uh-huh so if the king moves to g7 oh
yeah
then then this is pretty sweet we put
our knight in the heart
of black's position and then made on g7
so very nice invasion however the king
can move to h8
and this is a bit more complicated
because now if you go for 98
hoping to mate next move then actually
oh no you're queen
oh no you're a queen so
white has to be a bit more accurate here
knight g4
yeah knight g4 and this is another queen
sacrifice
however the knight is more useful on g4
because now
bishop f6 kmg8 knight h6 mate so another
beautiful knight bishop mate that's very
nice the same kind of same idea with the
bishop on the night that's very
beautiful
yeah it's amazing how well the bishop
and knight can work together
especially like whenever you have a
knight and bishop on the same color
square
then then you basically optimize the
amount of squares you're controlling
because the knight controls the light
squares
bishop controls the dark squares so they
can work very very well together if
they're placed appropriately
especially when when the pawn is on g6
and that the g7 square is free there's
no bishop they're controlling everything
that's true yeah because black gave away
the oxford bishop
yeah it just makes it much more painful
and
probably when my opponent took on d4
they were not expecting the queen to
just scoop up the bishop like no
wow that's so nice that that whole idea
so this whole sequence was actually yeah
it was kind of a nice flow
was this prepared or did you find it on
the spot
so this was prepared from a completely
different opening
and sometimes this is why it's nice to
expand your opening knowledge
across many different types of
variations because
certain ideas will carry over into other
openings
and i'll try and share what i mean by
that um
so the first time i i saw the sequence
was from an english opening and there's
a game
i'll show you real quick there's a game
between
andreikin and karjakin it was from i
think like a world blitzer rapid
championship
and it went like this karjakin was
playing black
he played so it's completely different
opening like english reverse closed
sicilian
um andreikin played d4 karjakin took and
then knight d5 so already like a similar
type of idea
uh bishop g7 was played
bishop g5 knight
ge7 and here
andreikin took on d4 and it's the same
same tactical flow even though like the
bishop's here and not
here and black's pawn is back um
the tactics are pretty much identical
bishop takes d4 was played
queen takes d4 same mating idf takes and
wow it's so similar that's crazy
and karjakin castled and then just lost
in uh
i think he resigned either resigned here
or played it out until mate
so he lost within 12 moves
doesn't happen too often at super gm
level
no that's crazy well it really feels
like the exact same game besides
the you know a6 b5 bishop a4 idea
just like a small difference in the
opening yeah yeah
well it's so cool so you had you you
could even premium until until the very
last like knight g4 bishop f6 part
when when you got into this like you had
seen the whole thing even the last
checkmate basically
yeah so it's weird because like in when
i played the game in the spanish i had
to think in the opening
and then once i got to like the position
with knight g4 i could kind of blitz out
the moves
and uh i knew what i was doing so
yeah anyway um
yeah this is one of my more favorite uh
favorite queen sack traps
from the spanish yeah so hopefully i'm
giving you uh as
like enough inspiration to add some
weapons to your
opening arsenal you are
inspiring me not just to improve my
openings but just to play more fun chess
i'm feeling very inspired no to be
honest like this is really really cool
these are some really cool traps
uh yeah i love seeing traps i i don't
know
um they're easy to follow and
they do they they do their thing you
know they lead you to a really good
position so
now it's it's it's been great i really
like them i feel very inspired
that's great yeah and they're more
memorable too like they give you more
motivation
than just like learning the first few
moves of strategy like
sometimes if you learn a trap you you'll
be more motivated to actually get it
in a game um
let's let's go into like a more main
line
because what i've shown you so far there
are maybe more offbeat lines
um i'll show you one of the more common
variations where if you play this if you
play spanish against
stronger players it's most likely
they'll follow
like the main main line which after
bishop a4
most people play knight f6 you castle
and then here there's different ways for
things to branch out
uh most common is bishop e7
which is known as the closed spanish if
black takes this is open spanish which
is a bit less common
main line is d4 i don't really want to
get into this because there's a lot of
theory
and uh i'm not like a super specialist
on it
so we'll start with bishop um
let's imagine okay white will play
rookie one
main line defend the pawn and when white
plays rookie one
white has a threat and sometimes people
learning the move order of the spanish
will confuse themselves
um early on and and end up losing a pawn
so most people here will play b5 which
is the best move
some more beginner players the so-called
noobs
will castle here not realizing white had
a threat
with rookie one and this is where white
can actually
go ahead and snag the pawn and take on
c6 and then take on
e5 because there's no longer this idea
queen d4 the rooks on e1 defending e
pawn
queen d4 knight f3 and black's not
winning anything back
because if knight takes e4 in that
position then we can just kick away the
queen or
or queen e2 maybe oh after queen d4
knight f3 we hit the queen
oh we hit the queen yeah right so black
has no time to
like take the pawn or defends it um so
i've seen
i've seen a lot of people like fall into
this uh in the past
so most people most people will play um
b5 here
here we retreat bishop b3
and at this point we're only scraping
the surface
of like the mainline spanish and there's
so many different
types of lines every line has their own
kind of name
um there's a common one
have you heard of the marshall gambit
uh i have but i can't remember exactly
how it goes no
but i've heard of it okay so the
marshall gambit emerges after castling
white will play c3 most common move and
then d5
um and it's a gambit that black plays
like d5 is the start of the martial
gambit
i don't want to go into this too deeply
but i want to just introduce you to it
because something like most spanish
players should
should at least know of at after takes
takes white can win a pawn
takes on e5 and then trade so light just
won the e5 pawn
um and it looks like white has good
initiative
but after was it pawn c6
um this is very very theoretical
and very common among like super gm
level play
even lower level play too and there's a
lot of ways the position can branch out
but in general black will go for a quick
attack like
d4 bishop d6 rook goes back queen h4
and it's one of these lines there's like
over 20 moves of theory in like multiple
branches
you really have to know what you're
doing um
so because of this i usually like to
avoid
the marshall gambits entirely as white
yeah that was so like cool how
like it seemed like uh why it had
initiative but all of a sudden like
three moves black
just just created this attack and you
know started
having a lot of finisher too yeah yeah
like slow motion replay like white snags
upon
attacks and knights the problem
sometimes this will be a problem
in the spanish or other openings where
you commit to an early c3
it hinders your queenside development so
the issue for white is um
queenside is very slow to develop and
black gets a lot of initiative with
attacking the rook
targeting the h-pawn and the black
bishops especially are
are very much ready to come into play
so um yeah so it's playable
but uh maybe not the type of opening to
go for is white
if you don't like to defend from early
on
no i mean yeah i don't like to defend
from early on so
okay so i'll share i'll share a line
where you can be the one attacking from
early on
and it's one of my favorite lines to
play
against usually if i know my opponent
will enter this position
and they like to play the marshall i'll
intentionally go for this position
and play a move that a lot of players
aren't ready for and
it has a lot of traps to it the move is
d4
um which i think is maybe the fourth or
fifth most common move
like other moves involve d3 or h3 or a4
which are also known as like
anti-martial lines because
they avoid the marshall but d4 is by far
the most aggressive line
the very first time i discovered this
move
i was actually playing the black side of
this position
and i got completely destroyed within
like four more moves from this
from this point um it was some online
game
a few years ago but i still have like
the scar
like the memory still haunts me um
but sometimes it's good like when you
fall into an opening trap then you learn
it then you can use the same trap
against future opponents so i ended up
picking up this line
and now you're showing it as well and
now i'm sharing it with the world
so the secret is uh is exposed
but i remember when i encountered this
as black i thought oh after d4
i can get something similar to the
noah's ark trap
where i can take twice we trade
everything on d4
then i play c5 c4 and trap the bishop
so that was my hope so i took on d4 with
the knight
hoping for takes takes takes c5
and black will win a piece like black is
already winning here
um that's not what happened
after i took on d4
white hit me with um some really nice
home-cooked opening preparation
i think i'll just go ahead and share the
move here
um yeah th the move is bishop takes f7
just kind of coming out of nowhere
um but as as we start digging into the
lines we'll see the point
um of course i i take with rook taking
with king is just uh
black falls apart um then my opponent
took on e5
and turns out black is still okay here
what i would have had to do is play rook
f8
lose back the knights and this is double
edged
like i guess both players still kind of
have to know what they're doing
in the game i thought it would be better
for me to save the knights
and then just trade on f7 so i played 96
and this was just an online blitz game
so i was still moving pretty quickly
i saw that after takes takes um it's
some material imbalance white has a rook
and pawn for knight and bishop
which is usually like it's usually fine
for the side with the
extra minor pieces however
white has one move here to just destroy
black if white doesn't have this move
then it's completely okay for black but
likes to move and win
material by force
um e5 maybe because you have the
queen f3 check yeah e5 multi-purpose
remove the knight open the diagonal
prepare queen f3
and black is losing
something no matter what i forget what i
played here but uh
i lost pretty quickly because wherever
light moves and
um yeah black is dead
so it was a painful experience but it
was a good one to um
at least become aware of this bishop f7
move
how do you play this with white like so
people can see this or is this the
moment where you share this with the
world
um trying to understand the question i
played this with white
once like after that game i trapped
someone with this exact line
yeah but then i studied more like
branches of the line and i discovered
more
possible traps as well so
it was kind of the the introduction like
this variation inspired me to
investigate this d4 line further i just
imagine if your stream has seen it
before
or if i oh oh this is the first time i
think they have
maybe once or twice but it was at least
a year ago
i haven't shown this in a long time
okay like usually i i stick with the
london opening
or i like to play ponziani too so i
don't play the spanish
too often and then i think a lot of a
lot of people who watch like they don't
catch every stream so
this should be new to to most people
watching on my stream
that's awesome wow it's so cool that's
such a sneaky line that's so beautiful
bishop f7
definitely yeah it's kind of the power
of opening preparation is if you're
if you're well booked uh early on or
even like well into the middle game
then you're prepared with um like
computer ideas or computer preparation
i will say bishop f7 is computer
approved
and uh i think it's like best case
scenario
it's equal for uh for black so
um i can share a few more things from
this line um just to try and like if
there's anyone who who wants to learn
this thoroughly and develop a rapid tour
around it
i'll just share like the main branches
um
the other so there's a couple other like
common moves that can
take with the d-pawn or take on d4
or play d6 if takes on d4
there's not any like immediate traps
here but white gets a pleasant position
after e5 essentially chasing the knight
back to e8
if knight g4 we just play h3 so 98 is
already
not what black should be desiring and
then from here
white can play c3 just gambling the pawn
to accelerate development
and even the whites down the pawn here
uh computer gives almost plus one for
white
because black is so passive yeah
then you know i feel like if you're down
a pawn but still like the computer
thinks you're
you're quite a lot better like that's
when you really know you have it that's
a very good sign yeah because compute
like stockfish is usually materialistic
yeah exactly um it usually favors the
side with more material
but uh not in this case
so the most solid move black
can play here and it's the most common
move is pawn d6
and then um the move i like to play
is pawn c3 now i should
note that there's a slightly different
way to get to this position
because sometimes instead of castling
black will play d6 immediately
and then white can kind of transpose
into that same variation by playing c3
now there's no martial gambit black's
committed to d6 right away
black will castle and then d4 so there's
a couple ways to get to this line
um if you play it through this move
order c3
castling d4 is is already still an
offbeat move
the main line is h3 which then can
branch into like
maybe 10 different variations depending
what black does
but um a lot of people play h3 here to
prevent bishop g4
yeah i like to go for this line allowing
bishop g4
but there's some kind of unique tricks
and traps associated with
allowing the bishop to come here even
though white center is under more
pressure
if you know how to deal with it um it
can still be pleasant
so i know we're diving deeper kind of
into the middle game it's not like the
other traps where
they come straight from the opening but
uh
there's there's still a lot of richness
from uh from this position
for sure for sure and i i think it also
like
gives a much uh better understanding of
the whole position i feel like
definitely yeah especially if you see
how things unfold into the middle game
and you'll kind of know what to expect
when you're you're playing the opening
um so white has to be careful here
because black is threatening to
essentially take on f3 take on d4
potentially win material or
damage light structure on the king side
so the best move to keep everything
covered is bishop e3
defending d4 at the same time leaving e4
hanging
however we're setting up a trap uh this
pawn is poisonous
if knight takes e4 white to move and
punish black for being greedy uh
bishop d5 yeah bishop d5 and
common task like sometimes the way you
find tactics is just identifying
which opponent pieces are not defended
so both knights are not defended
bishop d5 attacks both um
so we can say the e pawn is defended by
tactics
uh from here there's a couple variations
um and now
now we're approaching like the more high
level
kind of opening preparation which uh
this is one of my favorite lines i'm
showing you so i'll basically reveal
some very high level opening preparation
reveal some lines that um not too many
like stronger players even
are aware of oh wow
so for part of this you'll have to bear
with me because we'll
we'll like look into some deeper theory
but
uh i'll still try and make it
understandable
so main move is pawn takes pawn
pawn takes pawn and then black has two
options black and played knight a5 or d5
are are the main moves
um debating which to show first
i'll share knight a5 first um
which i think is the most common
variation black goes
for the bishop pair but also goes for c5
like very typical spanish idea for black
and the main move by far from this
position
so this is still so-called like
um what's the term theory like it's been
played hundreds of times before
so if you're a strong chess player and
you have a pretty um
thorough repertoire it's likely you'll
have studied this position probably
studied bishop to c2
the move that i like to play here is
straying away
from main line theory and it's a very
rare move but i found
found some cool traps with this move is
knight bd2
which is kind of anti-positional because
we're giving away
what should be like a strong bishop um
but the point is after takes takes
um we we get some half open file we uh
we pressure the a pawn
[Music]
but then if we go a few moves further
black will usually play c5
then white has some really interesting
way of seizing initiative
with h3 hitting the bishop bishop h5
most natural
and then g4 and the way i first
discovered this line was uh
was actually just using uh the engine
and the engine this was like the
engine's top line and
very few people had played it before and
this was like a few years ago
i was like preparing for an opponent who
didn't end up going into it so i just
kind of saved it
as um as kind of my uh my secret
preparation
um but the point here even though
white's kind of overextending on the
king side or king is still on g1
usually you shouldn't be doing this uh
without good reason
um white is going to be the one like
pressuring the king side more
effectively
and from here there is knight h4
and this is still opening preparation
even though we're getting kind of deep
into the middle game
yeah um knight h4 is a kind of a key
move
that makes this variation work for white
and the point
is again we're leaving our e pawn
hanging
but it's a mistake for black to take it
with either the knight or the bishop
and we'll go through both moves um so if
knight takes e4
white to move and win material
um i guess knight
takes g6 because then you can take the
work as well
yep knight takes g6 removing the
defender
and black could take on d2 but then we
take on eastside with check
and then take and uh we win material and
we're guaranteed to win material
whatever black does if takes we take the
knight
so that doesn't work for black what if
bishop takes
e4
oh yes our knight is hanging as well on
h4
our knight's a little bit vulnerable but
black's pieces are more
more vulnerable here yeah i feel like
this is the type of position where
uh everything feels like it's hanging uh
maybe just g5 g5 again removal of the
guard we remove the knight from guarding
the bishop
and uh yeah g5 even though our king
seems really exposed like we're winning
material and
black won't get much uh much
compensation for it
so because the e pawn can't effectively
be taken here
on the next move we're ready to play
knight f5 with some kind of nice king
side pressure
where the pawns support the knight and
even though black has a bishop pair we
have
more more central control more space a
lot of pressure on all areas of the
board
so there's more analysis to be done from
this position but this is just
kind of the at least extent of my
preparation like it's nice to kind of
blitz this out and
get the opponent thinking uh from from
early on
that's so nice i mean having a knight on
f5 is is just amazing wasn't it caspar
if it said that a knight on f5 is like
an
extra again like having an extra pawn
almost in a position because it's so
strong
yeah i i'm not familiar with the
kasparov quote but i know the ben
feingold quote is knife f5
he just says knife f5 because the knight
is like a knife
it's uh stabbed in different directions
knight f5 not knife f5 okay that makes
sense yeah
knife f5 or knife f4 yeah it's a common
type of attacking uh attacking weapon
oh no that that looks amazing wow
ah it looks like white has so much space
and just has so good pieces as well
yeah and like the engine will say it's
it's approximately equal here
but it's very dynamic there's lots of
bounces and
if you want to play for a win and also
surprise your opponent from early on
i think this is a nice nice variation to
study and
if i were to play this like if i were to
prepare this specifically for an
opponent
i would probably try and prepare this
even deeper from here
and understand like what my my follow-up
ideas should be
if i if i should be playing like some
h4 h5 or eventually g5 or sometimes f4
e5
a lot of different directions white can
take with uh
the king side attack yeah
ah but but this this looks this looks
great this is awesome wow
so yeah so this one i don't think i've
shared before
maybe i shared once before but uh this
one should be
pretty new for most people i feel like
we're learning so much like
inside information right now
yeah and like this is i guess not the
typical
like just beginner lesson where i'm
showing i'm sharing the basic traps i
guess we did that
earlier but this is uh just a glimpse to
what
higher level preparation can look like
um i'll share one more like very high
level
prep which it's a recent novelty
that uh i've i've managed to play like
once
maybe once online once over the board
and it stems from this position
so just as a refresher um let's look at
the other move order like if black
goes for a marshall wants to play
wants to respond to c3 with d5 do you
remember the move i show here for white
like what is the most aggressive move
and do some memory test
memory test okay these are not good for
me um
the most aggressive move oh yeah it was
d4
d4 good yeah sometimes when you're
learning a new opening like
i know for you maybe you won't play this
like 100 going forward but
uh always good to kind of review the
moves initially
get them into memory okay so d4 we saw
d6
white will play c3 so we transposed to
um
this sort of variation where we allow
bishop g4
um i didn't mention this earlier but
this is known as the yates
bogo lugo variation
i will never my whole life say that word
out loud
honestly i didn't realize this had a
name until
now so um learning something new
but okay
so we play bishop e3 we can say oh no my
pawn
but then we have bishop d5 so black will
usually take
take back and we just looked at knight
a5 and then knight d2
here we'll look at the other option for
black which is pawn d5
which is a bit more venomous
um because black is trying to
pressure the center right away um
now we play e5 black will play knight e4
and then from here we can throw in h3
hit the bishop usually bishop h5 is
played
and now we play i think the the main
move is knight
knight to um c3 but the trick you remove
is knight d2
and i remember actually i do have a
story about this one too like how i
discovered it
i was playing in the 2015 philadelphia
open
it was the last round and i was sitting
next to
i believe it was jeffrey zhang
playing white against andrew tang
now this was like six years ago so they
were both
much smaller children back then but
jeffrey like
unleashed incredible preparation
uh from this position and then a few
years later i had remembered like
jeffrey's
amazing prep i used his same prep
against christian carilla
um at the i think it was a 20
2016 or 2017 national open
right i basically used a really rare
variation i would not have known
otherwise
now knight d2 on the surface looks like
a blunder
because black can take and already it
looks like white is just losing material
we can't take with knight if we take
with bishop we lose a d-pawn
if we take with queen we get skewered
however this is completely fine for
white because we can take with
queen asking to get skewered
and then we just play queen c2 we lose
the rook we win the knight
um i know it's kind of a mess but engine
will give
already like close to plus one here for
white
and that's a good sign given that we're
down material
uh the reason being okay we're hitting
the bishop this pawn is gonna fall
yeah um i checked the games earlier like
usually black will take
and then save the bishop and after
the move king h2 white has full
compensation because we're going to win
the pawn we're going to get a king side
attack
ideas f4 f5 and extra rook for bishop
for black doesn't really mean that much
no i mean the bishop pair as well
in this position and this bishop is
completely out of play
in no shape to actually defend the
king's side no so bishop h6 is an idea
wow so some players will just walk into
this and get into trouble like right
away
going for the material this is so cool
that's so nice and you remembered it
just by
by sitting beside beside him or did you
like check the game after
something i remembered so i was just
like
casually looking at the game and then i
remembered
that maybe a few days after i i wanted
to see like
if it had been played before and there
was like one
gm level game from from this variation
but what i showed you is not like the
meat of the preparation
because after takes takes andrew tang
did not play
bishop b4 he took on f3
and the reason why it was so memorable
is because of jeffrey's next move
was not pawndix f3
and i remember he just blitzed out the
next move and andrew thought for like
20 to 30 minutes so
if you want you can try and find the
move here for
for white yes and
find what used to be an opening novelty
okay in the meantime i'm going to try
and bring in like the
the first grand master level game that
featured this variation
just to show how quickly white won i
feel
so lost um it's a really
weird confusing position especially if
you haven't seen it before
i'm looking at both chats a lot of
people saying rook c1
i think one one person in my chat good
job ten
oh good job to not very good player for
suggesting
a very good move i'll go ahead and show
it
is queen c3
oh leaving the like just
white's temporarily down a piece and
it's black to move
but uh the knights attacked and the
bishop still attacked
this is kind of pure engine preparation
we're still asking to get skewered
yeah if you kind of need to spend
a long time like digging into all the
lines to fully understand this
but every single line like white just
emerges better
if we first address bishop before it's
the same thing
pretty much as we just saw could even
transpose directly
which we already know is better for
white
like it's the same position um
so bishop b4 is no good
if black i think most people take on g2
actually what i want to show is a game
let me see if i can bring
this in as
a new yes i just pasted the pgn of this
grand master game
it was between ponomariev playing white
against elianov
as from the ukraine championship in 2013
which i believe was the first game to
feature this queen c3 move
and the game ended in 15 moves with
white just
executing an amazingly beautiful
kingside attack
sacrificing like multiple things of
material
wow so i think we'll just we'll see how
the game unfolds
um first of all white does lose a pawn
because black takes on g2
and black played knight b8 but there's
already like full compensation
because there's c-file pressure there's
g-file bishop pair
more space in the center so
i think a lot of people even the engine
can be materialistic because you just
you count the
the pawns and you favor the side who's
up material but
sometimes you have to consider the other
factors to know who's actually for
choice in the position
yeah um and white kept kind of
exerting pressure move the king over to
get the rook here
f5 was played i think an attempt to
maybe close down the position
the light kept improving and
yeah some gradual build up got the
battery
rook f7 was played and now there is a
really cool move from lights
um because the last few moves have been
a matter of like optimizing the position
trying to improve uh the pieces for the
best squares
and there's one piece for white not
doing too much
in the position is this bishop
and the bishop even though it's aligned
with black's
things it's uh it's just blocked by the
pawn
so it's a lot more useful on the king's
side
so really nice maneuver bishop d1
looking to go to
h5 and hit the rook and try and trying
to provoke g6
and this this move eventually allows
light to crack through the position
uh that's pretty nice yeah so g6 was
played immediately
white still goes for bishop g5 or bishop
h5 is the g
pawn is pinned yeah
uh bishop f8 played bishop f4 white's
still improving
um and with this move there's ideas of
e6
as a resource yeah um
yeah so queen yeah so if queen e6 which
looks like a normal like blockading move
black is just walking into a tactical
massacre with bishop g6
and everything falling apart
every single thing wow so usually the
queen is a worse black hater because
it's like the most vulnerable like if it
gets attacked
it has to move away so queenie ate some
uh
desperate attempt to hold on but then
very stunning finish rook takes g6
wow i'm sure this is all calculated um
after takes
takes um because now the this diagonal
opens the king is more naked
bishop g7 played now e6
every move is basically just a punch in
the face
real question so much to play against
yeah like box it's painful just to look
from black's perspective
yeah it's like the pieces are are so bad
and like
just completely passive queensland lying
with a bishop this rook's attacked
this pawn is monstrous queen seven
interesting because like in the movie
before before queen c5
um why could i have gotten like rick
takes g7 right and then just like on the
queen for like a
rick and bishop but white's pieces are
so good that they decide to not even do
that
that's a really good point yeah rook g7
the i think what most
people would do just to simplify yeah
and get the material advantage
but um white still has a threat and just
exerts more pressure
so rather than cashing in we will
eventually cash in for more
yeah um so queen e7 and then bishop d6
like everything attacked in the position
queen h4 and final move
free rook we don't really care about the
pawn because rook g2 and the bishop
covers
diagonal and then we're meeting or just
winning all the material
so that's crazy
and these are like two like really
strong ground masters as well
yeah these are um like ponomarev is a
former
like former world champion i think at
the time they were probably both top 100
in the world
so and this was like this game was
a lot of it was just opening preparation
like queen c3 was a brand new idea and
then black was
under immediate pressure yeah going into
the middle game
so wow that's that's that's very nice
anyway yeah so maybe we'll end with that
just as a nice uh
a nice high level game i know we we
covered some more basic traps some more
high level preparations so hopefully it
was a good mix and
i hope it inspires your uh your spanish
cooking too
it it it will it will i will be doing
that very soon no but this was this was
great really
like uh it was also great that you
started showing like more simple traps
and like simple ideas and then that you
went from that to you know a bit more
difficult stuff and then like more
like mainline stuff and then showing
like some games with that as
examples because i feel like when you
see games you just
i don't know it feels so much more
natural than just trying to like
memorize moves basically
sure yeah you get more appreciation you
get to see like how
how things unfold in different stages
and
try to show some uh some different
flavors too so
um yeah this was super fun for me
because i usually don't show
especially spanish openings on stream i
usually like to stick with my
the ones that i specialize in so i
appreciate you
you asking to do this